OK so. Here
they are talking with. For our
story project and Today's are necessary.
As well so yeah.
My experience in
Brooklyn like memorable. I was here all my life
I was born and raised in Brooklyn. I was raised. I was
born in the original section of Brooklyn which is a mixed neighborhood.
I'm
African-American and mostly to neighborhood at that time was like
Tino and talian and then from
there we moved to Park Slope which is like a melting pot and you would find
all different races in Park Slope you can find you
know blacks Hispanics all dishes just a
mixture
and so you know I guess some people consider Park Slope a very upscale
neighborhood and then from partial I moved to Brownsville
and so this is very different this a really urban neighborhood and then
from Brownsville. I found
myself here and she said that. Yeah I don't know what Pfizer is where they
are these
places as I say I'm a ten year.
One and because you know approaching my safety and so I
probably I've been here nine years and I was in Park Slope nine years and I grew up and I was
in Ridgeway for nine years some like that so you
know I had the visa for like where where you're at when you're at each of those places.
And what your experience of the neighborhood
were OK and growing up in bridge were broke when it was.
You know old school. You know I'm a pilot
of the late sixty's and so it was very much a
community and in the truest sense.
Everybody went. Everyone's spouse everyone but we everyone looks
out for each other we play we each other on the block we all had the
same dinner time. We was we all had the same place
on and so everyone knew where everyone was so it was easy to go to
other people's
homes and what is it like
going to school their memories
of growing up and growing up in the area. It was a
very protected neighborhood because all of the adults watched Alsace
and so you know that I had a sense of adults what dolls and
children with
children and children stayed in their place and I felt protected. I
did feel protected. I think
that you know when you come from a big community and you know everyone you know we didn't have
any of that like gang violence and things that N.H.L. A Everybody pretty much looked out
for you when we lived together and we went to school to
get me I mean they were gangs in different communities like East New York Brownsville. But
it was and is violent and is prevalent and so you know just
sounded like it is now you know
like it's crazy but I think that things
have changed because you know that was back in the early seventy's that
I'm talking about when I was the original Brooklyn and so back in the
early seventy's. You know we're just coming up or for the sixty's
in that whole sixty's
movement civil rights and all that kind of stuff so you
know people flower children bell bottoms I was Wayne Bell bottoms
and stuff like that and you know it was a different hour. And
so now as
we move along you know urban life
is developing and you know you get in a concrete jungle students are doing
all kind of thing you
know and they have been. And they gather there's a breakdown of the family that all whole community thing I
was telling you about started to diminish people started to go to work moms used to be at
home in like early seventy's and then as you progress
on it today.
A.B.C.. You know I think people pretty much started like. Both parents probably started
working away I saw
it in your own life your whole life
but this is a well I had a stay
at home mom but
by the time we moved in we got the parks Well you know it was hustle and
bustle and it was like you know you and miss middle
school and you know that you see you get a new approach
in high school and life is changing and there's hustle and bustle
and finding high schools and all kind of thing so you know.
The transition
was a very big one coming from you know original Brooklyn and
then wired up impacts well then everyone
so serious and everyone's about a career. It's a big
change yeah yeah. And you said you are living.
And then I moved to Brownsville which is a really big change because you
know there are a very urban neighborhood like never talk or you say it's
a gang is violence is drugs issues
and and. You know that really
put fear into me because you know kind of live like a sheltered life
until then even though I live in a mixed neighborhood I never really experience
racism and isolation but in Brownsville. I did that's when I became
aware that racism is a serious problem in Brooklyn you know and you
would think it is but you know each section of Brooklyn is different so if I went
to you know. You know how would be we had the incident with
the young man do you remember his name. I can honestly more fun he was running than
a car meaning it's been a
bad
start when I say it sounds to me I'll tell you but you know in this juice you know
it's a melting pot you have Chinese
here you have
of Hispanics beer Attalia fear
and everyone claims destruction and you know it's a
very curious place it's a mountain tired of people but it's very territorial.
Yeah because if I go in a block and I go to this Pakistani neighborhood I did
care
either you but I mean you don't like just stop you right usually.
You know and she says you know sometimes everybody to my Avi
Zohar the store you know what a different culture you know you can some people can
be self-centered that you feel intimidated and just go to go when you don't use you know you divide.
You know make you turn around and not mothers or do certain stores on Ocean Avenue.
If I go there I will go to early in the morning like you know soon as the sun comes up and I know they do open I
go and get my vegetables and I'm out of there because I know the attitude.
Of Deputy cologne. I know which stores. Well I mean I mention the neighborhood. You know in the city but at
that but you
know and also like when you hear people
money like if I hand you a twenty dollar bill for my groceries. I don't
want you to Dole my money on the
counter and then the next person behind you to wonder and in front of me you didn't do
that today and you understand so is your understanding dynamics of what I'm
saying from
the you say you when you realize this racism but that is of
the do of this of experience when I really like
it well it became real to me because you
know it's our open neighborhood and you
know there's drugs the exile
and this. Stereotypes and. You know I think many
people buy insists there are ties here in Brooklyn. Because that
with the media
puts out a fact immediacy to whole lot of stuff this going
on where this Politics Show issues for when you know they hype it up
because they want to Saunders favors in magazines. So if you really want to know the truth dealing
with scorn and you have to be involved with your community and you know not if you can you just got not
as a rabbi going out and meet people you know and when I go to places if I
see free brochures object. One of everything up to bring it home for the readers like
a novel. That's the only way to go no
I think that you're very right because you know you could get a perception
that this is a very welcoming and open place
Brooklyn is like never carries sayin. You know
maybe some of the perceptions about Brooklyn is driven by the media
and that is Robin is all although well year to year is all oh
work is not does the media has a lot to do with a lot of negative stuff that
is portrayed
in different neighborhoods. OK you don't really hear in media go out and say look
at these college student or look at these high school students who are volunteer and to
cancel you know cancer hospital or volunteer for children hospitals
are nothing to do children now as I'm marching to do things are not taking place but you do
have children and tunics and
young you dead are doing exceptional things and nobody talks about it unless it's a
group of
people like these young ladies here who were going inside the
trenches you know to really she was gone and
exposes. You know the same life for us as a people
we don't hear about college tours the less you listen the W.B. LS For W.L. I'd
be. OK you know their college tours but we're talking about
college talk like that so we don't have enabled opportunities to a lot of things and are saying give
me stuff on a silver platter because I don't. Kids and I MAKE THEM WHERE
WAS THERE WE GO TO changes because we're you know as we were talking about
Brooklyn so my mind is in a different place Kate will be really talking
about what you're talking about as being a black person living in
Brooklyn. OK Wendy radio talk about that. No I'm saying
this is all good to me right. This is good
but you know you know I want to direct my my conversation because I
was had a certain train of thought and I was thinking about what my experience
was growing
up but I don't like we were talking about racism so it
is appropriate because you
know you are tapping into you know your perceptions
and experiences and you know that's important
this important the last things you said is true I think people see
things
on news won and channels to it
depends on what cable companies
and so that is limited the media is very limited shows
limited neighborhood
shows Long Island arrives and most of things
S.-E. come from Long Island and I live in Brooklyn. So you
know it is strange and it doesn't seem right.
And it changes your perspective because if I'm seeing it every day and I start a so seeing
what I'm seeing
with Brooklyn but is really long island it could be considered bring more
action if you want to say you but you know I feel like not
enough news and people say that all the time because there's a lot of crime in Sheepshead Bay is
still the first thing people say is wise and on and
media is all around here you know what happened on Larry told me
they all kind of stuff. And so when necessary
is saying is true because the police department once emitted dead. They.
The crime statistics why exactly is they were pre-trained them to be.
And so that you would think that most of the crime is
happening in places like Grand surreal in East New York when just as much
crime is happening here she said bay any not more so as.
You know all you have to just open up the bay news and you see what's going on and we see that people are
getting carjacked you really get the it's always amazing.
You will see that they get mugged at the subway station over the Internet a
bus stops on Ocean Avenue. You
know we're each year from April to the original of July. I
mean everyone you know one after another one would be an attack to bust up five six thirty in
the morning. You know get a choke hold in between in one night and coming out of the
building and you
know and if we didn't password via phone call like she would call me or one of
the other girl did you hear so much will happen to such and such address and what women you know
but when I'm out a deal so I stop on to dealing with like today
don't talk publicly and in our community. OK so it was just by word of mouth and I guess
it was a ramp
the thing that was going on and I don't know this because you have two different sections of the night out here.
I don't know Desta reason why you
know it's not easy news is Camp suppressed.
There was a newspaper and I want to tell you one is the baby news yet on its
Korea life and she said they bite
puts a lot
of the stuff that goes on in Niger development.
They those tree paper is a popular report in
which news one there than you and the rest the news
channels that we have out here but for the most part
I live in here for the not the nine years I've been never tarries been here for much longer
than me.
It's been a very good experience because we have the song. Marash we live by
marine park and we have a nature reserve center this is a
very secluded area and so that's why I say we like out here by the
water
and it's a big difference from Brownsville is a much
better place in Brazzaville but it is still an isolated place
and you know pretty much
this neighborhood is a makeshift like Russian you hear from anybody on
the Chinese. Irish you define everybody out here.
You know is
a melon patch and for the most part people out
here especially if you're going to a Garrison Beach
because we're actually on the border. If you go a couple couple blocks
over will be in Garrison Beach and that there is a very racist prep
place for blacks and certain white because if you're not
Irish then you're going to have
a problem. You know Marano about the ethnicity you know but I know I don't go down that way
soon because I mean people and I don't go down that way because the stories that I've heard. I mean
there's no stores down here for me I don't have all my kids are grown and what not but I just
don't venture down that way.
So
if you know. There it reaffirms what I was saying that you know Brooklyn.
You know is outside of looking every night. Oh I want to go
to proclaim it seems like such an exciting plan excuse you know there's
so much to different people but when you get here you find out there's so
many different dynamics going on this is a very
complex place.
But why. What made you move so she said a year after raising your son here
whether they're like.
Well I had a couple of choices and. I chose to come to she said
they because I like water.
And so we are by three bodies of water we got Plum Beach.
We guys. We have
it in the rain
part where I was saying in a nature reserve. That is the end of the Hudson River so that enter
the Hudson River and right here and she today.
And
of course we have Coney Island there is bias. And there still Lana
Goshen isn't it.
If
I started on the harbor. There.
Yes So I really was attracted by the quietness.
There's a lot of green space here. And they seem like
such a nice play but what isolated.
What made you leave came from Brownsville to
get. I came from handsome Basil because I want to do Billy get out of
Brownsville because it was so much gun violence so much crime
I drive. It's not it's not it wasn't a very good place
to raise a child so I have my youngest son
he's nine years old and then I have a oldest son. There's twenty six
years on so I was really lucky and to pretty much get my older
son away from that kind of
environment because to Basle was a place
with black teens would be getting shot every other day
and you know you always say this is my son going to be next.
What
have you a great year old as you say how different are
eighty year old are you.
I think my oldest is more street smart because it
is not an event going on here and she said they for the most
part and even the schools here. The schools are different my son goes
to a school and Gaston being too.
And if we were in Brownsville. It will probably be a C. on.
Because as you know many schools in urban areas the deal with minority children
or poor performing schools in S. a fact. So you know
there is a difference academically there's a difference. Socially. I think
socially my son is
more developed then my older son would have been I mean he
was exposed to a like a lot of
violence there. So
either you talk about other things about living.
Criticism or other areas. Well I
always would think as a community. You know we
don't have much out here. And she said that is really nothing much
has
no club down here. There's no do we have a movie theatre. It's about
it but net the next three
cinemas arning you know that was still going on and on to movies
on my D.V.D.'s out of my
home. You know I mean what do you
think the best my perspective I just feel that there's no in a
same area.
It's not so much entertainment just nothing cultural for you down
here. Yes ma'am God is nothing out here for these you know like oh yeah you
know I don't you see young Sis get on a bus they dress to deny they going to work.
I'm tired to see a Muslim brothers hanging out on the corner. I know. OK I
do speak to you know I ticked all used to ask you because I used to volunteer one ninety
four I was a kindergarten kids I did after almost seven years on love into
death to see them now in high school or just to maybe go to college you know
and when I see them it makes my heart so
happy because you're on the right track and I always try to give them encouragement. They
don't get that a lot of the London dollar had responded ones that don't know me but most of the kids out here know.
Am I so
but in terms
of you can get job training for women any woman can go to
job training but you don't have nothing qualified for the brothers or the Latino or
the minorities crude and I want to just keep you know individually labeling. OK
so if you are night I'm not saying that a lot of the you
to not look a boy different but what do you have right here or does
nothing out it is not black churches like that so here
we don't have the one places that they don't want no Larry don't have our Ok this is already in
and I'll be no accounting for
like you know but it is totally. If you don't care if it's on
a parent.
Like I said I don't have money for tutoring I was a single parent.
OK so I worked my kids as much as I could to keep them on point but they started school when he was three
and four years old that in the sixty's when he started
Headstart death of my children got in and then found a will for style in a put in a got a
better
education and I did a comparative thing I compared the books to my kid
Ted Bundy other neighborhoods to what the children were doing in my neighborhood
totally
different totally different when I got to south poles to computers.
There were no computers in East New York where I was raising my kids and when I went
to when. When I moved to bedside days are computer is because of Mom
fight to get them into a better school in S. what I told the parents when I was launching you don't have to come every
day I came five days a week from eight known until four thirty in
the afternoon. You don't give an
hour usage home and you vigil does not happen and what we're you.
Like I told the board of ed No one has to teach your child to write scripts so what
is everybody doing now pushing a D.M. but not a
device. OK Do you know how did you know like I said back in the day when I went to school
you knew how to do the dictionary. You know you know everything about the dictionary. MARION
SCRYMGOUR it's cool. Because the way he's as he's in Garrison
Beach one ninety four was nitrogen and knew that when I first I was up for
all her greatest
work. I mean she does not ignore the script by you my kids knew how to
squeeze by by the time they were six and seven. OK I told my
kids can't speak correctly you couldn't come home with slime
where you can make in my kids were going to go Don't think just because my
kids went to a different Ariel school they got ridiculed they were to use on the school
bus and the kids laughter then when it came to the way the day talked which we learned how to talk
like
that because they spoke correct English and played it like I say you
gotta stop when you bring your kids home when he's really flustered not put a pencil in a
union talk to him. Don't you know in a God I babble babble so you got
to talk to him and you'd be
surprised children stimulate that you can see just when you stimulated the
a mind like I say now you look at that you look at the declassified is.
The jobs not only want you to have a college degree you got to be
bilingual. So what did the black mayor. What did
he say on he's going to start a curriculum to teach
or you just now get into twenty parroting that our children should
be given a second language. OK from when
you when your preschool definite need to start once you start talking making Falconer you need to be taught
a different language. Know you not and I'm not saying you just give them a language use your
teaching or words to make you
know how you say in Spanish how you say it in English or
whatever and you'll get it just how you teach them where you show a red apple this. Apple
is red is shaped like you know well the word or this arches round you teaching
in the circle and you teach them the color of it you understand that it's not hard.
We have been deliberately taken back with the education system in
the body it is just that under our. Oh
the part I was going. Why.
This community
needs artistic. I think
there with we there's not enough cultural things going on I think we have a
lot of different cultural groups and no one's really doing
anything as far as culture like we don't have we have one community center than
there and it's Asian and they don't want anyone but. Asian people coming
in we need something that breaks all of these little quick
scene groups. And
that just brings people together late
a different type of community center that welcomes everyone from the community if you go
across the street you go to the Y. is the Jewish King's Bay why they only want to cater to
Jewish people they only want to cater to Asian
people I had a and I had people be happy even to be happy in
these
conditions and even though I have the wire here you've got parents who can afford to take them to
why what is true this should be honest as you said you have a lot I don't get to go with after
you have to do what he did I was amazing I say would totally And then if I don't have the money going
to feed the meta data me wait for my men come
back what I think that was made she said a
better place is if we had more. Instead
I have an
isolated specific specific cultural events is that if
we just had places that were for everyone and sort of just seven
places
for the Jews the Russians just everyone. And so.
Like Neff said we don't
have. Like we have to travel to go to Brooklyn music. There's
no artistic endeavors out here. There are no social
clubs out here. There's nothing
there's no love you know labor the whales are in the Gulf right now watching it not in a
little circle of well I mean like you know if
you go to partial there's a this five restaurant on every block.
Is they use them to do a lot of the alley and all that how you got the
drugstore wasn't a food
stance of hey you want to be for real and that my back in the
day when you had to build a guest on every corner you had a mom and pop clean a storage unit
head of a lot
of minorities that all of this is honestly none of our people are here
to have a one man store here on Ocean Avenue and I'm hoping that from Fulton
and Flatbush I mean flap was you know students are always down to visit except
the brother that just opened up his fish store on Avenue the why is
it birthday date and what is a business
day very again gave him a lot but you can count on one you David was how to end the
fish place on on on on Ave The Who else is out here.
Well for the most part I
was because we live in a house and still you
know we're like a handful of people like this Weiss
and begin and I feel like this is my neighborhood because you know.
I live in a
development and you know we work in the community nets it's been in the community for a long
time but the best death the truth I mean like
in order to accomplish with Nessus saying we would need our
own people to be more politically organized and they are
not yet it is very homey or they're like.
The that would entail. Get in and
resources and exposing them to the political process.
This is how to
build this is and things of that nature this
this suggest a whole different
example ballgame I. Because even though I vote now and vote has
I got it wrong.
OK I don't really see a difference in a thing other than effect yes my brother
President Obama he's in office
but. The powers that be around him has made his
job of a zillion times harder than it needed to be because of who he is
well OK well what but on the other point when is volume time
enough community who do we see it evolve
polls know and out the little
man active role model so I know that al Qaeda is doing them out
when we went in when President Obama was
running our whole neighborhood came out. When the next
primary came in who was
vote the
elderly you understand what I'm saying the elderly were voting.
OK And we need to understand debt and like I said I'm not a political person
but I'm learning as our goal or that if you don't get involved. You don't have
a voice for the shower of all parents and I'm sure you can be sure
you their own go into a opiate Cup wasn't to people came out in
this neighborhood and I know I
don't want it but it is the antithesis of eight
thousand people that live in our development and. You know if you think about the whole neighborhood
just barrels of people
but our politicians actually really win by several hundred votes in S. A
friend I was
just you don't know unless you work in an a poll worker so you and no one would
know
that that they went and bought a couple of hundred votes is is
this
is crazy but it's on monday through no one's coming out so
well and you never do as a primary a couple weeks ago. I happen to buy a deal years on ebay.
I don't even know today was a primary. I read a paper just I took magic newspaper
OK I saved it OK now these hold three a thing was six pages full of all kinds of
different judges and it wanted no pick
his I don't even follow from that I have carried that. Get off
the street if you want us to continue to vote but I have a
name doesn't mean nothing to me.
And this is how politically be able to spin the wheels the way did they
do. OK And then every election you come up all the paper punch
or did you know they got a key chain. Really you're going to me into a mood you can
fix the machine for the everybody gets a chance of
all the areas in Maine. If after nine when he can make a
new decision. You did it has a hour to do absolutely nothing.
The other way around for my landslide last on sight.
No no no no no no no
no I'm just a conscious observer.
But one less. So it's
about she said De Lay was when they work with made me
be happy to live here is that. If I did
see more businesses that were owned by people of color. If
I did that because I saw isolated I said that
before and people who feel that way. I don't think that the Asians will still isolated
because they have things geared towards
them but you know in the Russians because they had their stores or restaurants or
whatever but for me and mess as African-Americans. I
feel isolated I said this and to be given this the way I felt and so you know
that's important if I
had things that I lightly I like going to the
museums you know we have we do have a movie theater but there's not a lot
of places and people can go out here she said there's still you know the
kids feel that way too I know it is sure that they still my business and here
like in other neighborhoods like they read you can go to
these fun places for kids gym places
and you know for a dollar and but then again those places cost more. Me and everybody doesn't
have much use do we have a whole race of young children that are going with out on
the weekends because they have nothing to do in a payments can't afford
it. The switches they can't afford and like I said look at the car here.
OK so my car six kids and I want to take my kids to the Brooklyn
Museum and the donut. Because I noticed
and I'm sorry
the the. I don't know if this is all
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll
be quiet.
Our goal because everything just I'm sorry I'm not sure it's something new when you are
making some very valid
points and I really appreciate is this conversation I
really love talking about Brooke was all really the same
day really appreciated. So thank you for sticking to you.
OK.